when I especially thank Chris for
reading that challenging Gospel reading
and I hope that many of you will be able
to stick around for the talk the sermon
talkback afterwards so we can wrestle
through it together it is not out of
avoidance that I'm not going to preach
on the gospel it's that I especially
wanted to focus on the Epistle of James
this week but that's not to say there
aren't 25 sermons in that very Gospel
reading will you pray with me
Oh God may the words of my mouth and the
meditations of all our hearts be
acceptable in your sight O God you are
our rock and our Redeemer amen
the Yale chaplains office where Ian and
I work is located in the basement of
Bingham Hall right across old campus and
in the chaplains office we dispense many
things we are just down the hall from
one of the freshmen laundry rooms and
probably most famously we dispense free
ice cream this seems to be like manna
for students wandering in the dining
hall wilderness they hear free ice cream
and they come flocking every afternoon
when they're when they need a little
sugar pick-me-up the free ice cream is
one of the trademarks of chaplain Sharon
Kugler who knows from many years of
experience that if you feed them they
will come and they have student traffic
in our office has increased
exponentially since Sharon and her ice
cream arrived of course it's not just
about a sweet treat it's about offering
a relaxing place where you can just flop
down on a couch and study for a while or
you can talk to somebody maybe debating
the afterlife with somebody of a
different faith tradition it happens
every day it's just about opening the
door for a bit of sanctuary in what is
otherwise a rat race The Dispensing
doesn't stop with the ice cream we
dispense free quesadillas at our study
break last Monday we dispensed hundreds
of candles the previous Monday out of
for any lay we dispense tissues lots of
them we dispense water and tea and
business cards we dispense names of
other religious leaders to be in touch
with if you'd like to explore Buddhist
meditation or another Christian
fellowship group but the one thing I've
really been wishing we could dispense is
the very thing we've run out of actually
we never had it in stock to begin with
the very thing I often wish I could give
away in the chaplains office but that
we've run out of is easy answers easy
answers about why bad things have just
happened easy answers about what you
should do next in a relationship easy
answers about knowing the best method of
finding out the will of God what God
wants you to do these are questions not
easily answered we have plenty plenty of
questions in stock but not easy answers
and let's face it the last few weeks
here at Yale have been really hard for
this community and for many of you
individually to transitions can stink
tragedy is heartbreaking finding your
place here especially if you've just
come to Yale or New Haven can take
forever and I have wished more than once
lately that I could provide easy answers
and take away the pain suffering might
be an accurate description of what many
of you have experienced lately which is
why I was really drawn to this James
text James in his letter to early
Christians gives lots of practical
advice about how to be a good Christian
in the face of adversity and he should
be good at it he was Jesus brother he
had walked along he had also been the
pastoral leader of the first church in
Jerusalem James was very devoted to
Jewish law and his letter takes on a
fairly legalistic tone but I'm hoping
that his prescriptions for being
faithful will offer what even a
well-stocked ice-cream cooler cannot
guidance for how to get through a
tough time as an individual or a
community what James says is important
but it's almost as important to take
note of when he says it the passage for
today comes at the very end of the book
of James after he has spent quite a
while reminding them how to get their
acts together just before our verses
today James gives a really harsh warning
about wealth and those who use their
wealth and power to abuse others our
lectionary for some reason skips right
over that maybe the people who put the
lectionary together thought it might be
too hard to hear but it's an important
thing for James it's all about community
and to live in community you need to
live in ways that serve other people so
this fits the tone of the rest of his
letter morality is at the center for him
so after sternly warning the wealthy
James moves on to prescribe patience for
those who suffer he assures his readers
that Jesus is coming back soon so it's
time to get your relationships in your
behavior in order but then he offers
this be patient therefore beloved until
the coming of the Lord just hold on
after all of these prescriptions about
how to live together and how to be
faithful the letter finally closes with
these verses heard today about prayer
what a way to end a letter no matter how
much his beloved community has messed up
James encourages them to pray for one
another when all of the rules end up
being impossible to follow
maybe prayer will hold it all together
maybe prayer will hold us all together
so let's hear again what James has to
say to his first century Christian
community and what he might have to say
to this fall semester 2009 Christian
community he begins or any among you
suffering they should pray and
immediately two sentences into this
I've already constructed a counter
argument in my head James really James
just pray really that's it then what
will the suffering stop
James is a little too preoccupied to
deal with my skepticism and keeps
trucking right along or any of you
cheerful they should sing songs of
praise indeed James it is easier to sing
and be joyful when things are going well
maybe I don't have to have that argument
with James after all it's good but then
I keep reading and it gets more
complicated fast are any of you sick
they should call for the elders of the
church and have them pray over them the
prayer of the faith will save the sick
do any of you struggle with this part
too
are you also remembering when a loved
one got sick and you prayed with all
your might and they didn't get better
are you also remembering that desperate
sense that God was no longer hearing
your prayers
James just says pray pray pray this is
what James is prescribing for tragedy
especially the tragedy of sickness so
the elders come and pray or the pastor
comes to the hospital bed and prays or
someone who hasn't found the words to
pray in 25 years finds himself kneeling
on a hard floor begging God at times
like this prayer can feel like the only
thing to do and at the same time the
most impossible thing to do a theologian
named Roger rakes draw struggles himself
with chronic illness and wrestles with
this very passage from James he knows
from his life experience of his illness
and others that prayer does not
guarantee healing he humbly reminds us
that when it comes to healing God's ways
are sometimes not our ways rakes draw
writes in response to this passage from
James we are to ask for healing knowing
that God is able to do what we ask
however we are to leave the outcome with
our wise and gracious God who may or may
not choose to heal this for that
specific instance we come with
confidence to the great physician
who healed the sick in the cities and
villages of Galilee and Judea we do not
however claim to know precisely what the
will of God is in every situation
I so appreciate how rake straw avoids
the temptation to provide an easy answer
and instead wrestles from his own
perspective of one with illness he
wrestles with this passage and well it's
tempting for us sometimes to just tell
someone who's suffering to pray and God
will make it better what is often left
when the dust settles and everyone has
gone home is that that sick person is
feeling very guilty and alone and
wondering if they're not praying hard
enough and that's why they're still sick
nevertheless prayer has power and this
is the paradox embedded in this text
even though we cannot control the
answers to our prayers even though we
can't just dispense easy answers by
praying there is still power when we
call on God there is power when we
gather as Christians to pray this
passage from James is particularly
unhelpful in one very specific way I
think because James implies a connection
between sin and physical illness and we
have to pause right there and deal with
that for a minute
many many people who get sick blame
themselves you may have had this
experience yourself was it something I
did in the past
did I not wash my hands well enough is
that the people I hung out with is God
punishing me and many people who go
through tragedy wonder what they've done
to deserve this
James is following the cultural pattern
of his day in linking physical illness
with sin but a lot of damage can be done
as you might imagine with this link
sometimes our actions do have health
consequences but we can't link all
illness to sin I think that really
damages both our understanding of
illness
and sin after she points out the danger
of the link between illness and sin in
the James Passage Barbara brown Taylor
offers this as a helpful framework for
this dilemma we find ourselves in she
points out that both illness and
wrongdoing or sin separate individuals
from their community's illness by
isolating a person physically from
others and wrongdoing by isolating a
person socially okay so if you're not
sure how physical illness isolates
people from their community can imagine
any of your friends who have come down
with a flu-like symptom order to stay in
their rooms for a few days for good
reason for contagious diseases and also
people who find themselves in the
hospitals for days or weeks and they
wonder where of all my friends gone why
if they stopped calling why is no one
visiting me
maybe we're just afraid of catching
something which in some cases again with
the flu is very appropriate maybe it's
also that we just don't want to see
people suffering
likewise if someone admits to doing
something wrong they are often pushed to
the margins of a group instead of being
brought back in into a helpful web of
support and accountability that churches
and other communities can offer no
wonder we don't want anyone to know when
we're sick no wonder we don't want
anybody to know when we've messed up but
telling both of these truths
it's just what James is prescribing to
his Christian community and I think also
to ours
he writes are any of you sick call for
the elders of the church he actually
puts it in the lab of the sick person to
ask for help if she or he can possibly
muster this drink to do it
and for us today are any of us sick or
when we are do we think about calling
somebody in this church community for
help do we think about reaching out to a
friend or are we afraid of what they're
going to think
are we afraid that they're gonna see us
as weak chances are though if you're
sick
you might not have stashed up enough
clear liquids and saltines to get your
strength back and maybe you need
somebody to help you don't be
embarrassed
try to call for some help there are
people ready and willing to help each of
us but they're not mind reader's often
your friends are sitting back trying to
give you space and wondering what they
can do to help you so if you have this
drink ask for it then James goes on to
call us as a community to confession
which is what Pastor Ian just did a few
minutes ago as well and we do each
Sunday here is there any other time in
your entire week that you publicly
announce ways that you have fallen short
things that you have done wrong I think
most of the time we spend our days
covering that up or trying not to think
about it and so here we do something
very rare and something very important
for a Christian community we remind
ourselves that we are all human and we
hear God's Word remind us that God
forgives all so we try to ask for help
when we need it and we confess when
we've messed up well this is starting to
sound more like church than some
impossible prescription from James about
how to live a perfect faith and James
goes on to another step that we do often
commending us to pray for one another
some people find it helps them through
their week merely to know that somebody
else is praying for them but think back
to your childhood did somebody teach you
the right way
to pray did you see pictures of other
little children with their hands folded
kneeling by their bed sides
eyes closed and thinking perfect
thoughts was that the right way to pray
did your parents teach you to pray maybe
a grandparent maybe you read about
prayer in a book or saw it on TV what's
in your mind about the right way to pray
I remember being very young in church
before I could really understand what
was all going on my mom let me color
specially during the long boring sermons
there are crayons in the back if anybody
needs them but when it came time for the
prayers my mom gave me that look that
little nod and I knew it was time to put
away the crayons close my eyes fold my
hands and think very hard about God that
was the right way to pray or so I
thought
who taught you to pray and when you
don't pray exactly this way do you just
have heaps of guilt about it
feeling like you're doing it wrong do
you ever wonder if you're praying wrong
and that's why things aren't going
perfectly our gospel passage for today
begins with John tattling to Jesus about
an exorcist John and others have tried
to stop this guy from casting out demons
because he wasn't following us Jesus and
Jesus reprimands John for trying to stop
this deed of power just because it
didn't look right there's a lot more
going on in that text as I said but I
think it's important this might be
dispelling our idea of one right way to
be a Christian one right white right way
to pray and Jesus goes on to scold
anyone who would put a stumbling block
in the path of these little ones who
believe in me I wonder if one such a
stumbling block that the church
sometimes puts in front of people is the
sense that there is one right way to
pray we do our best to teach young
children how to pray but do we ever
teach them how to pray when they're mad
or when they're playing outside or when
they're too antsy to sit still with
their hands folded do you ever find
yourself critiquing how other people
pray I think though we have confirmation
in the Bible that there's not one right
way to pray in fact many times you won't
be able to piece together words at all
when you're trying to pray and that's
very much ok romans 8 provides this very
familiar and comforting assurance the
spirit helps us in our weakness for we
do not know how to pray as we ought but
that very spirit
intercedes with sighs too deep for words
if you feel stuck in your prayers
maybe silence can be your prayer
sometimes tears are like prayers or the
words to a favorite hymn or psalm that
you've known for a long time those words
you can lean on when you can't put any
other words together maybe even listing
names of dear people who really need
Christ's healing maybe that can be a
prayer eyes open or closed hands folded
hands lifted up maybe even clenched in
fists in English or Spanish or Swahili I
think God is most interested in any
honest prayer we can muster however we
can muster it and we must keep learning
how to pray because our lives keep
changing
we must keep practicing being honest
with each other
and God we must keep praying for
Christ's healing in the world even when
the brokenness feels too heavy to even
bring to the foot of the cross God's
promised to hear our prayers is the one
constant amidst all of these changing
things even as we are still learning
what it means to pray Mary Oliver's poem
thirst is part of a larger collection of
poetry she wrote as she was grieving the
death of her longtime partner she names
her deep grief acknowledges her struggle
of faith and ends with the word about
learning how to pray as she finds
herself in this new awful terrain our
prayers change as our lives change and I
can't say this any better than she does
so I'm going to just let her words and
this sermon thirst another morning
wait with thirst for the goodness I do
not have I walk out to the pond and all
the way God has given us such beautiful
lessons Oh Lord I was never a quick
scholar but soaked and hunched over my
books past the hour and the bell grant
me in your mercy a little more time love
for the earth and love for you are
having such a long conversation in my
heart who knows what will finally happen
or where I will be sent yet already I
have given away a great many things
expecting to be told to pack nothing
except the prayers which with this
thirst I am slowly learning in the name
of Jesus the healer and comforter amen